president of the Hollywood Foreign Press
Association wanted to have a one-on-one
sit down with me and I'll be totally
honest with everyone here tonight I took
this job assuming they hadn't changed at
all
the elephant in the room bigger than
ever at the Golden Globes I'm here
because I'm black
one minute you're making mint tea at
home the next you're invited to be the
black face up in in battle white
organization
foreign
it is going to be funny it's going to be
poignant it will definitely feel like a
very different Golden Globes host Gerard
Carmichael doesn't hold back while
saying what the A-list room seemed to be
thinking
the Hollywood Foreign Press Association
which I I won't say they were a racist
organization
but
they didn't have a single black member
until George Floyd died
so do with that information what you
will how do you shake that past I didn't
think it's one about acknowledging the
work that's been done acknowledging that
more work needs to be done Hollywood
Foreign Press has has made strides to to
do what they know needs to be done as
the comedian recalls a friend put things
in perspective after he was approached
for the gig how much are they paying you
and I said five hundred thousand dollars
and she said boy if you don't put on a
good suit and take them white people
money
well he's one of a kind hilarious and
and so very handsome I think we're gonna
see it all when I think of Gerard
Carmichael I think of someone who
doesn't give a damn with the people who
run the organization think that he is
there and he is going to say what he
wants to say how he wants to say in our
creative conversations thus far I can
just tell that it's not just about a
monologue he has an approach that he
wants to bring to this job and I think
we're going to feel that for the entire
show we're coming in hot we really want
to focus on celebrating our incredible
nominees we want to have a sense of
community and just generally have fun
yeah the model cause a much needed
Icebreaker as the awards ceremony came
with a lot of baggage this year I am
here
because this is a country of Second
Chances
I am here because if I win I publicly
get to thank the people
that have put me here
so that's pretty great and I think that
you know entertainment like this is an
escape for all of us and I think the
last couple years we've all needed an
escape yes and I think that the time is
it's perfect it's like the perfect way
to come back on the 80th I thank the
Hollywood Foreign Press Association for
opening up their hearts and Minds to
understand that diversity really matters
and it really works
[Music]
foreign